alors c'est très intéressant parce que
j'ai pas si vous vous en souvenez vous
ai beaucoup parlé de ce retrait d'un
écran pliable et notamment du potentiel
du probable samsung galaxy mix qui
s'étale au final le galaxy de vol et la
cwa et qui prend le x pour son
smartphone
ça me fait rigoler est ce que c'est un
petit clin d'oeil allez savoir alors ça
très intéressant parce que je suis au
mythe un mec il faut dire chiant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous voilà à barcelone en ce beau
dimanche du mois de février on se
croyait parce qu'on était avec mon ami
mr perrier qui est juste devant la qui
se cache on est parti pour la conf de
huawei pour découvrir les grosses
nouveautés connecting de futures à mon
avis ça va envoyer du bois va y avoir
plein de choses hyper intéressante
lorsque je vous emmène ce que je vous
invite à venir découvrir ce moment c'est
très grosse actu au niveau des
smartphones effectivement le mineur qui
était présenté le chiot mis il ya aussi
de l'actu du côté de chez huawei et
notamment aussi du côté de chez samsung
il ya quelques jours je vous emmener à
londres pour découvrir les galaxy s 10s
dispute ce soir il faut monter la haye
oui ok ben mon temps à oasis est 10 plus
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez le
pré-commander s'il vous intéresse dès
maintenant vous ai mis un lien en bas
pour aller voir du côté de chez les
scouts
vous n'allez pas être déçus on est dans
le pavillon qui va accueillir la conf de
huawei dans quelques instants
en ouverture du mwc alors bon on devrait
avoir une annonce qui envoie du lourd
huawei ait bixi on a fait la photo que
ta faute aussi à ouidah surhumain
on va
michelin qui font un bon moment ça
extrêmement
et donc on est en place là
oui qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir droit alors
tu vois plus les combes sûrs d'eux
il ya quelque chose qui va cette fois
j'examine
on n'a pas eu ça mais là ce qui est un
truc qui se mordent
courbes la grosse actu ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
squash au risque et 192 certes mais
franchement la profession franchement je
trouve c'est la meilleure solution parce
que j'aime pour l'instant on peut sony
samsung on n'a pas celui de chiangmai
avoir à vous de tester en fait c'est une
mélopée en fait c'est un peu la bouche
et il ya tellement monde
devant le spartak et
derrière nous
c'est directement
impossible de travaux
c'est un peu compliqué donc pas le voir
de loin
on va découvrir deux mots ont fait
sensation en termes de pliage à mon avis
que ça à proto pour nico des enfants
morts
finition on se rapproche et regarde
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu'avec les refus
l'homme a du mal à ce conte
une petite fenêtre pouvoir voir le
design des recours maintenant ce qui est
très compliqué c'est être capable de
juger notamment autour des flexibles et
de la paix de nos enfants la charnière
est ce que c'est pertinent ou non et
c'est ça qui fait vraiment la différence
d'un rapport à la clé la rigidité s'est
vite reprendre la main fait savoir si c
tant pis si c'est insolite et drôle
frustrant c'est que ça fait des lois des
années concordantes aprilia il arrive au
mauvais moment impossible de les prendre
en main elle reste la charnière est pas
complètement
finalisé
ses positions et j'avais l'impression
qu'il arrivait le clip c'est qu'il avait
tout - bascule
il y avait un petit peu sur le milieu
par le clic c'est par exemple j c il a
dit qu' il ya entraînement secret de
fabrication
vous voulez quoi
veulent pas se faire piquer mais bon
c'était juste waouh présentation du
smartphone à écran pliable de huawei le
mexique s'annonce très intéressant parce
que je sais pas si vous vous en souvenez
vous ai beaucoup parlé de ce retrait
d'un écran pliable et notamment du
potentiel du probable samsung galaxy mix
qui s'attelle au final le galaxy de vol
et la cwa et qui prend le x pour son
smartphone ça me fait rigoler est ce que
c'est un petit clin d'oeil allez savoir
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
je suis au mythe un mec je veux dire
shiomi c'est intéressant parce que owen
nous a présenté une gamme renouvelée
d'ordinateurs avec le macbook x gros ça
on en reparlera ultérieurement il y
avait également le macbook 13 qui a été
présenté aux crs la ja le macbook 14
bon tout ça on en reparlera plus tard
tranquillement là on va se concentrer
sur un peu le l'effet waouh je ceux de
cette annonce en tout cas c'était le mec
tu x et et huawei c'est l'effet waouh
c'est le fairway
ce qui est intéressant avec leur copie
en cours ou souci vous vous souvenez on
a eu le modèle aux orioles un peu
l'histoire de ce marais qu'on a vu au cs
avec une charnière pas très bien finis
pas terrible il ya eu la proposition de
samsung a pas longtemps avec le galaxy
folle qui est bien mais cette espèce de
grosse encausse paraît un peu bizarre et
puis le fédéral tout écran sur l'avant
c'est un peu bizarre et là où ça
s'intéressent aux filles à ce que ce que
propose - ouais c'est que vous avez une
seule grande tablette en rapport avec
des bornes extrêmement fin et quand vous
leur billet vous avez deux écrans c'est
un premier écran de 6,6 pouces qui est
le plus grand écran avec un ratio 19,5
9e et un écran plus petit de 6,38 pouces
au format 25/9 et c'est sur cet écran la
a coûté que d'y retrouver les caméras et
lorsque vous l'ouvrez vous avez un écran
de 8 pouces alors j'ai tout noter là
parce que c'est pour étendre la 3 parker
2480 par 2200 celle 8 pouces alors sur
le galaxy folle journée à 7,2 pouces on
est sur un smartphone qui est à ses fins
il faut qu'ils aient ouvert il fait 54
mm et puis il fait 11 mm alors forcément
lorsque vous repliez pousse à toujours
plus épais que sur un smartphone qui
peut plus standard néanmoins l'effet
waouh c'est franchement aujourd'hui le
capteur d'empreintes digitales ont
directement sur la tranche sans le
bouton on off ça c'est pas une grande
nouveauté mais ça marche toujours très
bien et ce qui est intéressant est là où
ils ont mis un petit peu l'accent c'est
au niveau de la technologie star que
lorsque vous replier
les deux devront vraiment venir se
coller vous n'allez pas avoir comme sans
le sexe paille du royaume cette espèce
de deux parties un peu de vie au final
donc pas vrai gros boulot de trois ans
de recherche et développement de la part
de voix ou qui vraiment ne pourra le
prendre en main pas tout de suite
il devrait sortir dans le courant de
l'année 2019 pour l'instant on n'en sait
pas plus
ce matin moody's âge on voit que ça va
franchement bousculé pas mal les choses
en face d'une petite hache les
applications côte à côte
enfin le troisième application si vous
êtes vraiment gourmand multimédia pour
regarder vos vidéos
comme vous avez un seul même grand écran
pour avoir des morts à ses fins vous
imaginez une expérience montrer par
exemple pour regarder des photos on lire
un bouquin vous aurez une bien meilleure
expérience qu'il pouvait avoir en tout
cas avec un smartphone actuel il a un
triple module photo on n'en sait pas
plus au niveau des specs conception des
caméras les cas et connaissant la
qualité des produits de huawei est pas
surpris que franchement ça déchire et en
plus ce qui est assez marrant c'est le
tournoi dès qu'un effet miroir c'est à
dire que vous allez prendre quelqu'un en
photo ou forcément l'appareil qui
pourrait faire cette personne vous le
souhaitez et lui se voit doté comme avec
un effet moniteur ce qui fait qu'en fin
de compte votre caméra principale vous
sert également de cadre de cette fille
mais ça permet aux personnes que vous
prenez en photo de voir également ce que
vous êtes en train de faire donc ça
c'est assez rigolo pas smartphones qui
pour l'instant sera proposé dans la
couleur bleue interstellar qu'est-ce qui
est très sympa c'est qu'il y aurait
effectivement si une coque de protection
qui
montrer qu'ils allaient plutôt bien
d'intégrer à ses classes un smartphone
qu'il est complètement compatible 5
gilles lacelle j'y arrive c'est du gros
temps fort de cette année en 2018 on a
beaucoup parlé de 5g on a vu que la 5g
allait arriver en 2019 la 5e j arrive le
temps de la mort en france
falloir patienter encore un petit peu en
tout cas c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui arrive
le fait d'avoir ce smartphone compatible
5 g 5 actuel mais sur la 5g du futur
aussi si assez intéressant vous avez le
moden c'est le ballon 5000 modem 5 g et
tourne avec un peering 980 donc le fait
d'avoir ces deux belles deux perfs vous
allez avoir un smartphone rapide un
smartphone fluide la smartphones
compatibles cinq jours que ça c'est
vraiment une proposition très
intéressante vous avez 4 en plaine 5 g
smart phones et nous ont dit vous pouvez
télécharger un giga ans
trois secondes pas si vous vous rendez
compte c'est juste hallucinant vous
pouvez insérer soit deux cartes sim
première carte sim compatible 5g
deuxième carte sim maximum 4g mais la
plage la deuxième carte sim vous mettre
une carte micro sd a priori qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à 256 giga vous avez une
batterie d'un total 4500 millan terreur
l'idée d'avoir deux batteries dans un
match écoutez c'est pour gagner en
épaisseur et pour le coup c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt bien intégré et en plus de
ça vous avez de la recharge rapide 55
watts ce qui fait quand l'une des
meilleures vous avez recharger votre
smartphone 85% c'est juste hallucinant
ça c'est bien mais vous vous doutez que
c'est la personne qui va pas être un
cadeau cadeaux vous avez une version 8
gigas de ram 512 giga de stockage à 2299
euros c'est cher c'est très cher on est
sur le début des smartphones pliable
forcément savent pas non plus exactement
quelle quantité ils vont écouler est ce
que les clients et les consommateurs
vont répondre à ce type de produit ce
que ça va les intéresser
mécaniquement si ça marche les prix vont
baisser avec des propositions nouvelles
dans quelques années je suis pas sûr
tout de suite tout le monde se rue sur
les smartphones à écran pliable de
telles puces pour raboter
professionnelle parce que les coûts liés
aux usages
bien qu'à l'avenir d'ici quelques années
les smartphones écrans pliables
remplaceront nos smartphones actuels
mais ça va être vraiment très
intéressant voilà pour cette info mais
kick sont bien évidemment beaucoup pour
parler des smartphones est rempli à vous
savez c'est un peu mon dada j'aime ça et
surtout le fait de et capable de voir ce
qui va arriver à l'avenir de capter les
nouvelles technologies de comprendre les
enjeux
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire je vous dis
somatiques c'est à mon avis destinés
plus aux professionnels tout de suite
son côté multi tâches sont de la
présentation on ça va être hyper
intéressant et il va arriver tout
doucement au niveau du particulier donc
ça c'est cool vous invite à faire une
chose déjà assez à vous abonner comme ça
on va tous nous pour parler
vous serez informés mais maintenant on
continue la journée avec mon pote housse
bleus poussent bleus népalais en l2 et
maintenant on va filer à showstoppers
sauces soupes ou plus c'est un truc star
wars c'est un truc de star wars jeu sur
exactement et on va aller voir ce qui se
passe en termes de nouvelles
technologies intéressantes rigolote tout
ça tout ça quand c'était d'accord avec
ça je pense que d'accord et meego allez
ça ils étaient à gagner jouer très
embêté parce que en fait sont fous
complètement
ok donc là on va au centre commercial
ans en forme blanc a battu google maps
est simple et sur l'iphone x et sparrow
s'en fout en fait donc là on va j'ai
perdu cinq milliards
l'indétrônable viable il était super
beau mais il était saoul verts on n'a
pas pu mettre la main dessus sur l'eau
il est bien de 1300 date quand même de
quoi il a été annoncé à 14 heures et à
midi voilà je suis arrivé à barcelone
j'ai vu les affiches gens partout
nouveau gain de 5 mètres de haut dans la
ville à part cela il a l'air très très
beau et moins
mon épée - mastoc celui de royal et qui
voit là
oula viable bourg du boul
comment ça va les gars bien aimé train
de boire et manger c'était
je suis avec le mec le plus poissard du
mwh de témoin à la 2019 s'est pas encore
mon année en fait quand à la semaine
allait américaine prend l'avion glisse
son ordinateur dans la dans la prochaine
ronde avec les magazines et il se barre
à la bisou c'est pour moi du coup tu
veux du coup je loupe lacombe
huawei la chaire mier le showstopper bon
là on vient d'en sortir ces programmes
se marrer donc en fait j'ai passé une
bonne journée à l'aéroport
ça sera à délirer à faire le bruit à
faire le ping pong tu vois ça c'est
plaisant c'est formidable vous pouvez
pas juste nous laisser tranquilles en
fait il a cette fois ci laisse pas
tranquille à pourquoi toujours en
principe ce joie parce que quelques à
l'idée de partager la localisation sic
et les rides et en a marre laissez nous
tranquilles messieurs oui j'aime bien
bien bien